[Music]
there's a moment in the game viewfinder
that kind of broke my brain actually
there are lots of moments that broke my
brain the game is ludicrous but the most
mind-shattering instance came right at
the start when I held up my first photo
and walked right into it and even though
I knew this was a main component of the
game's world I still said to myself
there's no way this game won't actually
let me place a photo anywhere it would
completely break well everything but the
game did let me it encouraged me
demanded I keep smashing guidelines keep
tearing up the manual because viewfinder
is set in a world that breaks all the
rules
typically fictional worlds strive for
immersion limiting themselves to certain
parameters even if those limits are more
Fantastical than reality but there's
another kind of fictional world the kind
that shatters the confines of the status
quo so say goodbye to gravity say
goodbye to time say goodbye to space and
prepare for a voyage across realities
with no restrictions
so how does one navigate a world that
breaks all the rules simple you break
the rules right back and beat it at its
own game the world of viewfinder
consists of gravity-defying islands
separated by gaps that are impossible to
cross impossible that is unless you line
up a photo of a bridge and then simply
make your way to the other side
confronted with a locked gate just hold
up a photo of an open gate and pass
right through the world of viewfinder
might shatter the parameters we're
familiar with but it has its own
internal conventions that you can learn
if you keep an open mind
anything in the background of a photo
just kind of deletes whatever's in front
of it which can allow you access to
walled off areas that are otherwise
unreachable and anything in the
foreground becomes something physical a
tangible cross-section of reality you
can walk through thanks to some trick of
programming that to me borders on
miraculous
but it's not just photos that this
effect works on you can also enter and
wander through the colorful brush
Strokes of a painting or explore the
cartoonish landscape of a postcard with
a simple iconography transformed into
material objects even the scripples of a
child can become something corporeal
something you feel you can reach out and
touch it's bizarre at first but the
deeper you go into the world of
viewfinder the harder it is to remember
things ever working another way with
each new layer the rules of traditional
reality recede further and further into
the background and even as some things
start to seem off you pay no attention
as if you're trapped in a dream and need
to find a way to
our patent-pending somnoscope technology
provides safe and effective dream
therapy while you rest in the comfort of
our Flagship Clinic
the entirety of the 2019 game super
liminal takes place within a dream
that's not a spoiler like it would be
for most pieces of dream Centric media
the factor in a dream is obvious what
isn't obvious is how to wake up
like viewfinder superluminal is a game
that asks you to break all the rules and
see reality from A New Perspective
in this world if you pick up an object
and walk backwards set objects will grow
in accordance with your changed
Viewpoint it's a feature of the
Dreamscape that on paper makes little
sense yet somehow feels completely
logical and it also works in Reverse if
an object gets too big you can shrink it
down with a simple perception shift with
this reality bending ability outsmarting
the puzzle-filled world seems like a
cinch
but the world of super liminal will bend
reality right back the ultimate goal of
the game is to escape a labyrinthine
dream Facility by finding a door to the
waking realm yet this is easier said
than done because the facility is a maze
of false exits one hallway that seemed
to offer a way out was actually a forced
perspective illusion with an exit too
small to fit through another wasn't a
hallway at all but a camouflaged
sculpture meant to trick the eye once
the actual Way Forward was painted to
look like a dead end a deception that
caused me to stop trusting my perception
altogether
these Illusions are examples of
anamorphosis distorted projections that
require the viewer to occupy a specific
vantage point to make sense of them like
the puzzles of viewfinder they require
you to literally change your perspective
and embrace the strange new paradigm of
the world around you indeed many
sections of viewfinder feature a similar
anamorphosis mechanic yet notably such
Illusions don't just exist in the
virtual realm painted ceilings from the
1600s create depth using analogous
visual trickery those forced prospective
Taurus photos of the Leaning Tower of
Pisa fall into a similar category such
Illusions are simple even silly yet
though often played for laughs there can
be something disarming about convincing
optical illusions like having the rug of
reality pulled out from under you
many films use oversized furniture and
clever angles to manipulate the viewer's
understanding of scale it's in effect
often meant to be invisible not a rogue
pull but a harmless technique to create
a convincing fictional setting what's
uncanny about such effects however is
that the spatial Distortion is happening
within your mind modern cameras aren't
required these Illusions work simply
because our brains expect the world to
follow certain rules an expectation that
can be taken advantage of two
essentially warp reality
a broken rule in a virtual dream is one
thing but a physical optical illusion
can leave you questioning the waking
World wondering if the laws of reality
are truly as consistent as they appear
in the world of manifold Garden the law
of gravity is more of a suggestion
floors become ceilings stairs become
Bridges there isn't really an up or down
they're just kind of
is
created by American artist William sheer
manifold Garden might be advertised as a
modern puzzle game but the Project's
primary inspiration is the work of a
Dutch mathematician born in 1898.
the drawings of M.C Escher or Mazes of
impossibility using early perspective
Illusions and gravity-defying
architecture to create Landscapes that
could not exist and yet manifold Garden
through Modern programming makes these
worlds explorable
in order for this to work the geometry
of each landscape Loops infinitely you
can jump off any structure and know with
absolute certainty you will eventually
return to a place identical to where you
started as a result falling one of the
most conventional ways to lose in a
video game just isn't a concern here
falling is similarly de-emphasized in
viewfinder as you can rewind time from
any point if you make a mistake this
serves as a reminder that traditional
rules aren't what you should be focused
on but the lack of guidelines can also
leave you feeling somewhat untethered
even frustrated like nothing you do here
has any real consequence
navigating a world that breaks the rules
can be Often by Design aggravating super
liminal is probably the most upfront
about its attempts to provoke you and
notably it frustrates you not just by
removing guidelines but by creating a
logical guidelines of its own the game
will frequently demand you follow the
exit signs located throughout the
Labyrinth yet many signs lead nowhere or
are utterly incomprehensible at one
point if you trust the signs you'll be
trapped in a hallway that repeats
forever the only way to actually
progress is to pick up an exit sign and
use it as a ramp to escape outwitting
the dream with its own underhanded logic
it's super liminal will even break
conventions during moments like loading
screens periods most players might
consider a safe Zone at different points
in the game the loading screen will
mutate with the progress bar sometimes
jittering backwards folding through 3D
space or standing Beyond its typical
borders in one of the more literal
moments of fourth wall boundary pushing
I've seen in media even the title
doesn't obey instructions collapsing to
the floor if you click on it another rug
pull in a game constantly pulling rugs
it can make you feel like you're in free
fall why don't the laws make sense who
is in charge of this place
and why is this Rabbit Hole so deep
Lewis Carroll's 1865 novel Alice in
Wonderland tells the story of a girl who
falls through a rabbit hole into a land
of illogical characters in nonsensical
scenarios it is also perhaps
unsurprisingly absolutely foundational
to the concept of Worlds that break all
the rules in Wonderland signposts give
misleading advice sizes shift
unexpectedly brought to life in early
film adaptations through how else forced
perspective the DNA of the story can be
felt in pretty much every piece of media
in this video from Little references to
full-on character homages viewfinder
even has its own version of the Cheshire
Cat a figure that offers cryptic advice
about how to navigate in a logical world
because critically Wonderland is deeply
frustrating for Alice to Traverse and at
times even a little Sinister in many
ways it feels like the world of adults
from a child's perspective k threatening
and governed by rigid conventions that
make little sense the world seems a
meaningless puzzle made worse by
attempts at policies occupied by people
who don't realize the absurdity of their
own lives
it kind of reminds me of going to the
airport
the 2019 absurdist Adventure game jazz
punk opens not with a bang but with the
slow procession of an Airport baggage
claim the luggage leisurely inches along
as the name of the game Studio hovers
silently in the air like a signpost for
a boarding gate and then
[Music]
[Applause]
the game just absolutely loses it with
zero build up or justification it
launches into a nearly two-minute James
Bond style intro sequence the old school
Espionage imagery alluding to the Cold
War spy genre of the Game parodies but
it just keeps going and going the sense
of importance Rising the energy swelling
until it throws you spinning
into an extremely dull office space from
here the game becomes absurdly realistic
though you play as an international
super spy you have to sit down and
actually peruse articles as you wait in
real time for your boss to be ready when
the waiting is finally over your boss
tells you to infiltrate Soviet
intelligence then proclaims he'll be in
his wine cellar before pretending to
walk below his desk
[Music]
like most works of satire jazz punk
points at absurdity not just with a
genre but with various aspects of
reality the world it takes place in a
retro futuristic alternate history
version of the United States in the late
1950s is suffocating Under Suspicion in
bureaucracy yet though most characters
treat this atmosphere of Espionage
extremely seriously their attempts at
counterintelligence feel profoundly
unserious there's an agent hiding in a
mailbox who tells you to go away a milk
van following you around with a
completely unsuspicious amount of radio
equipment a senior officer who uses top
secret carrier pigeons to bake a pie
though gravity never inverts and space
never warps and jazz punk through its
parody of social conventions the world
feels just as absurd just as boundary
breaking as any other discuss so far
but there's one moment in particular
that feels different really in the game
you can sit in a movie theater and watch
a never-ending Loop of a commercial for
something called a swing wing and though
the product seems too absurd too
pointless to actually exist the swing
Wing is in fact a real toy from 1965.
one that was unsurprisingly discontinued
forgiving children concussions the
game's characters watch in silent
Rapture as if nothing in their parody
Universe can match the preposterousness
of our reality
during the height of Cold War paranoia
the CIA launched project acoustic Kitty
the plan which is real was to spy on
enemy embassies using a radio
transmitter implanted within a cat the
plan failed due to the shocking
Revelation that cats don't like
following rules it costs 20 million
dollars around the same time British
defense came up with Project Blue
peacock a plan to detonate a nuclear
warhead in the event of a Soviet
invasion on an eight-day delayed timer
the timer was to be set off by a live
chicken sealed within the Warhead itself
when the plan was Declassified many
assumed it was an April Fool's joke the
official government response was and I
quote the civil service does not do
jokes
it is after learning things like this
that the world of jazz punk doesn't seem
so absurd the fact that buildings have
both a fire alarm and an ice alarm
starts to feel only a few degrees
removed from the silliness of reality
this is a video about fictional worlds
that break all the rules but sometimes
reality feels just as Lawless and
arbitrary
okay now it's time to talk about an
airport for aliens currently run by Dogs
released in 2021 the game takes place in
well an airport for aliens currently run
by dogs as a result The Familiar
conventions of an airport are filtered
through two degrees of distortion the
dogs or weird floating jpegs of dogs who
run the airport have made various canine
specific modifications the bar serves
toilet water the bathrooms are full of
fire hydrants you get it due to the
dog's poor short-term memory if you ask
for a boarding pass you might get 50.
yet even more challenging is the other
layer of distortion since this is an
airport for aliens all the signage is in
in unreadable language and the game does
actually expect you to navigate to your
flight on time a process that can make
you long for the rules of a real Airport
but here's something that playing an
airport for aliens currently run by dogs
helped me realize all airports are
fictional and by fictional I don't mean
they don't exist you can of course go to
one but everything about an airport from
the frustrating baggage claim to the
endless signs to the dividing barriers
are ultimately something invented a kind
of collective fiction of procedures and
rules we all buy into and I'm not saying
all these procedures are meaningless if
a pilot decided to stop following the
lines of a Runway there'd obviously be
consequences but the lines of a Runway
have no inherent meaning only the
meaning we've assigned to them
sometimes it's only possible to
recognize the arbitrary nature of these
invented places when we see them from A
New Perspective like when they're empty
or you know run by dogs it's bewildering
when a fictional World breaks with the
rules of reality but many of the rules
we follow in reality or their own kind
of fiction
does it sound like I've lost my mind a
little bit it's hard to stay grounded
when exploring these worlds particularly
the very last one I want to look at for
this video kooky is not really a game
not really a movie
um it exists kooky is made up of simple
icons floating at a void and if you
steer towards one it will be placed in
the context of a surreal painterly
environment many of these Landscapes are
about as abstract as they could possibly
be without being completely
untreversible with some made up of just
a few flat images in a completely white
Abyss each region is inspired by a
different painting by Italian artist
Enzo kuki hence the title of the game
Cookie's paintings are similarly enigmas
a maze of Doubt entangled
interpretations yet what's most
interesting about kuki the digital world
not the man is how rarely I felt lost
when navigating each environment even
when things were at their most abstract
I could always find some way to orient
myself latch on to some familiar
iconography and watch as the landscape
took shape in many respects kooky feels
like the ultimate proof of how few rules
we need to stay grounded how our brains
can conjure a full-fledged World from
the simplest 2D projections exploring
the Realms of kuki made me re-evaluate
how I think about some of the other
pieces of media I've discussed thus far
I think there's real significance to the
fact that the most frustrating fake exit
in super liminal is also the simplest
it's just a painting of the sky propped
up at the right angle to look like the
real thing and while your annoyance at
being Wiley Coyote is still fresh the
game offers of relaxation room inside is
a projection of a patch of Sky the same
patch of sky that all the fake exits in
the game are modeled off of it's
emotionally overwhelming knowing that
the goal of the game is right there but
it's just a 2d illusion but here's the
thing everything about the world of
super liminal is a 2d illusion the same
is true for the world of viewfinder both
from an in-universe perspective
everything in super liminal is a dream
and everything in viewfinder is well I
won't give that away here but also in
the most literal way possible these
worlds are flat renders on computer
screens no aspect of them has any more
real World depth than another the fake
exits are no different from the real
ones the same holds true for all
fictional worlds in visual mediums
whether they break the rules or not
every film you've ever seen is an
illusion essentially a series of
photographs played in quick succession
to break your brain into thinking the
subject is moving there are hand-drawn
discs from the 1800s that basically work
the same way deceiving you into seeing
motion when spun at the right speed the
photographs of viewfinder the false
exits of super liminal these feel
uniquely illusory but from a certain
point of view all fiction is its own
type of Illusion
to return a final time to Alice in
Wonderland as the novel wears on the
Victorian era of rationality that adults
have taught Alice consistently fails in
an inherently chaotic world it is only
in embracing the irrationality of
Wonderland in accepting that the rules
are nonsensical and can be broken that
Alice can return home or more accurately
wake up from a dream
sometimes the value of Worlds that
shatter conventions isn't waking you up
to the ways reality doesn't make sense
so many things in our daily routines are
arbitrary the result of looking at the
world from a particular point of view
sometimes that can be comforting or even
useful but sometimes it's worth changing
your perspective
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious
see you in the next video